papà ti devo dire una cosa certo cara
sono qui di e non è facile papa e dunque
ti devo dire una cosa che è da tanto
tempo che ti voglio dire però siccome
faccio un po fatica perché non ti
preoccupare stai calma tesoro abbiamo
sempre avuto confidenza dimmi cosa c'è e
c'è che papà niente che io mi sposo ti
sposi poi sposarsi sarà un'unione civile
no no no no proprio mi sposo proprio in
chiesa con l'abito tutto ma dai
in chiesa ma con chi scusa ti sposi e
con con marco con marco ma dai sei
eterosessuale si papa è un po che te lo
volevo dire sono sono etero
ok non ho nessun problema nessun
problema io sono aperto lo sai mica
eterologo tranquilla tranquilla non sai
qual è il problema un po adesso chi lo
dice la mamma si potrebbe mai immaginare
un coming out di questo tipo
no un coming out come questo non ci sarà
mai
e per fortuna perché non è ribaltando le
problematiche che si risolvono non è per
esempio molestando gli uomini invece
delle donne o picchiando i bianchi
invece dei neri che si crea parità
equità libertà no no no no non funziona
così
eppure dobbiamo risolverlo il problema
di questo coming out è un problema per
moltissime persone già il termine coming
out io devo uscire fuori devo devo
confessare le mie inclinazioni sessuali
o sentimentali perché devo confessare
una confessione
cos'è un reato non è una confessione
ore non può essere un reato l'amore sarà
sempre una cosa bella inclusiva che
include tutta l'umanità non si può
confessare un amore eppure il coming out
continua a essere un problema
tanti ragazzi e ragazze che che si
confidano con i propri genitori vengono
cacciati di casa e siamo ancora in un
paese dove vi battiamo su questa
benedetta legge contro l'omofobia ancora
il coming out è un problema io sogno una
società in cui il coming out non esiste
neanche ma perché mai mai basta dire non
so sto con gianni sto con carla sto con
filippo sto con marco che prima si
chiamava marca ma non è un trend sto con
con francesca che prima si chiamava
francesco che problema c'è no non è così
per molti casi non è così beh devo dire
il mio caso è stato un caso fortunato
anche perché non era un vero e proprio
coming out
diciamo che è stato un cambiamento di
rotta io ero sposata e poi diciamo che
invece di andare contro l'iceberg come
il titanic
ho cambiato direzione e quando ne ho
parlato le reazioni sono state davvero
sorprendenti la prima cui l'ho detto è
stata mia madre
no ho capito bene stai con una donna
figata figata assoluta no ma dai ma è
troppo bello ma guarda che ti ho sempre
detto e gli uomini su tutti i bastardi
ma no ma finalmente posso sperare in un
po di felicità per te amore ma cara o
presto mela presenti è ancora più
incredibile è stato mio padre sono
d'accordo con la mamma
gli uomini sono tutti dei bastardi
tranne il sottoscritto naturalmente ma
poi cara dai cosa ti devo dire io ti
capisco anche a me piacciono le bionde
ancora più incredibile è stata la
reazione del mio ex marito che allora
era ancora marito io mi aspettavo si
arrabbia sta invece non solo non si è
arrabbiato ma anzi mi ha incoraggiata
mi ha spinta da marito veramente
democratico onesto e progressista cara
non sarò mai io a castrati tesoro ma tu
devi prendere la tua strada ma io io
sono felice per te guarda se questa è la
tua vera natura tutto non devi soffocare
i tuoi sentimenti che non sono certo io
il tuo carnefice assolutamente tesoro ma
vai per la tua strada
ma sentiti libera vai vai per la tua
strada vai vai ho avuto il dubbio che
volesse liberarsi di me
ancora adesso mi ronza nella testa a
questa domanda ma insomma che cosa devo
dirvi
sono stata fortunata ma come dicevo
prima non per tutti è così ma poi se
pensiamo che ci sono paesi dove ancora
confessarsi omosessuale significa essere
incarcerato seviziato seviziata
torturati gli omosessuali vengono a
volte uccisi per non parlare della
transfobia dell'odio dell'accanimento
contro i transessuali ma perché
che cos'è questa omofobia transfobia
questo cancro che divora le nostre
società occidentali e orientali che
cos'è lo motobi ha allora viene dal
greco
ovviamente come tutti noi sappiamo
omofobia quindi fobia paura di chi ha un
amore per lo stesso sesso
chi sta con persone dello stesso sesso e
da che cosa origina questa omofobia già
sigmund freud aveva notato che tutti noi
abbiamo una parte omosessuale tutti noi
siamo bisessuali chi più e chi meno chi
in grande quantità e chi in meno
quantità e poi ci sono state altre
ricerche altri studi e per cui è emerso
che gli omofobici in realtà non
accettano questa parte omosessuale che
hanno per esempio è uscito uno studio di
recente sul journal of personality and
social
ecology secondo i ricercatori gli
individui omofobici vivrebbero un forte
conflitto interno tra la propria
attrazione verso persone dello stesso
sesso è l'imperativo a reprimerla questo
conflitto causa quindi paura intensa e
viscerale degli omosessuali
atteggiamenti discriminatori ostilità
verso i gay
eccetera eccetera poi c'è stata anche la
chiesa cattolica che per molto tempo è
stato una sorta di baluardo di rifugio
per gli omofobici è ma la chiesa dice
che allora io sono andata a leggermi e
tutti i vangeli anche perché io sono
cristiana non cattolica ma cristiana mi
sono letti tutti quelli apocrifi quelli
non apocrifi quali quelli legali quelli
legali tutti non c'è una sola parola
contro l'omosessualità in generale gesù
non si occupava proprio della sessualità
non gli interessava aveva altro per la
testa
c'erano altri cambiamenti che gli
stavano più a cuore e non ne parla però
ultimamente qualcuno all'interno della
chiesa ne ha parlato ed è stato papà
papà far parte per patata papà papà
francesco che adesso mi sono emozionata
nel citare il papa anche perché un papa
che dice queste frasi emoziona ha detto
chi sono io per giudicare un gay che tu
sia gay non importa dio ti ha fatto così
ti ama così e non mi interessa il papà
ti ama così devi essere felice per ciò
che sei
la chiesa dovrebbe chiedere scusa e gay
gay non vanno discriminati chi
discrimina che non ha un cuore umano
eccetera eccetera eccetera quindi anche
l'ultimo baluardo per gli omofobici la
chiesa e sta crollando non hanno più
nemmeno quello dietro a cui rifugiarsi
va bene però dobbiamo risolvere questo
problema dell'omofobia questa questa
malattia perché è una fobia fobia
significa una sorta di disturbo
comportamentale allora di fobie ce ne
sono tantissime al mondo
pare che ne abbiano trovato addirittura
500 cinquecento fobie io ho voluto così
elencarne qualcuna
giusto per capire di che cosa si tratta
allora acrofobia per esempio la paura
delle altezze l'amato fobia non è la
paura di amare ma la paura della polvere
c'è chi ha paura non so la casalinga
forse della pubblicità ha paura astra
fobia non è paura di paolo fox ma paura
dei tuoni dei fulmini
poi c'è la velone fobia velone fobia non
è la paura di belen ma è la paura di
aghi e spilli o altri oggetti appuntiti
poi c'è la pronto fobia che lo nella
paura di brontolo ma la paura del tuono
l'euro tofo bia che non è paura della
moneta corrente ma paura dei genitali
femminili e cene parecchi
e poi c'è lo don dopo b a chi non ce
l'ha ora di andare dal dentista la fa
smo fobia paura dei fantasmi lazo fobia
diffusissima e della paura degli animali
specialmente topi i ragni scarafaggi o
affini bene e come fanno gli psicologi
ad affrontare questo problema delle
fobie come le curano gli psicologi
comportamentali hanno trovato una sorta
di terapia come si fa allora
sostanzialmente lo psicologo avvicina al
soggetto fobico lo stimolo cioè quel
qualcosa che gli fa paura con un
avvicinamento graduale prima da lontano
poi più da vicino per esempio non so i
ragni uno alla fobia dei ragni lo
psicologo fa vedere il ragno in una foto
prima lontano poi avvicina la foto poi
farà vedere il ragno dentro in una teca
e poi farà vedere il ragno senza teca
poi ragno si avvicinerà schiaccerà il
ragno e tutto finirà insomma una volta
avvicinato il lo stimolo sempre più da
vicino non fa più paura si dice diventa
neutro o e allora se facessimo così con
gli omofobi
non si potrebbe avvicinarli no con
cautela è perché non si sa mai
tipo tu sai che quella persona è un moto
ma allora tu magari cominciò avvicinarti
a salve questa signora signore bella
giornata caldo al freddo bello insomma
poi sai che non so quella persona li
aspetta sempre 84 tu vai sempre
aspettare 84 c'è sempre in ritardo
questo 84 è come va
oggi e piano piano i confini dice c'è
uno scambio di idee poi un giorno la
invidio lo inviti a prendere un caffè e
c'è sempre più scambio poi c'è fiducia
per far vedere delle foto perché gli
psicologi fanno vedere le foto tu fai
vedere delle foto prima da lontano
magari dei tuoi parenti amici no che poi
non fare vedere quelle del gay pride con
le paillettes e karima è meglio di no ma
foto normali che se il supermercato
anch'io vado a fare la spesa e piano
piano sempre di più si crea questa
confidenza poi non dico che diventiate
amici però insomma si crea una relazione
a quel punto quando c'è confidenza e
fiducia
am spari fuori il coming out dada e
secondo me sei diventato un neutro lo
stimolo è diventato neutro la persona
non farà un plissè non fa una piega
ti accoglierà serenamente ma che ti
abbraccia e lo potevi dire prima
ma come tu prima andava indicata ma no
sciocchezze perché avvicinato ragno può
sembrare una cosa un po folle
però secondo me funziona quantomeno ecco
quello che voglio dire che potremmo
iniziare a provare a fare un po di più
no ad avvicinarci ad aprirci a includere
e includerci forse qualcuno si chiuderà
forse qualcuno si schiuderà ma
sicuramente qualche cosa di bello
prima o poi fiorirà grazie
grazie